[音乐]
军事法庭规定，任何军官若让士兵不带武器上战场，将被军事审判。同样，我们也应该保护学生，因为学生不应在缺乏沟通能力的情况下步入社会。
因为你的成功在很大程度上取决于你的口头表达能力、书面表达能力和你的想法质量，顺序就是如此。我深知我能做好这件事，因为沟通的质量——你的演讲和写作——主要由这个公式决定。
这取决于你拥有多少知识，你在实践中运用这些知识的程度，以及你的天赋。注意，天赋这一项非常小，真正重要的是你所掌握的知识。
这个观点是几十年前我在太阳谷滑雪时突然领悟到的。我听说那是名人周末，其中一位名人是玛丽·路易斯·雷顿，著名的奥运体操运动员。
她在跳马项目中拿了满分十分。我听说她滑雪是新手，所以当合适时机到来时，我向一条新手坡道望去，看到一个年轻女子失去平衡时做出那样的动作，我心想那肯定就是她，那个体操运动员。
但我随即想到，我滑雪比她好很多，而她是奥运选手，不是一般的奥运选手，而是杰出的奥运选手。我之所以滑雪比她好，是因为我掌握了知识和练习，而她只有天赋。
所以，只要你有足够的知识，你就能超越那些可能很有天赋的人。这就是我今天的目标，我的承诺是：今天你会看到一些可以加进你演讲技巧库的例子。
其中一些例子、某些技巧，也许只有一个，能帮你得到工作。这是一个非常非线性的过程，你永远不知道它什么时候会发生。
但这就是我的承诺：在接下来的60分钟里，你会接触到很多想法，其中一些你会纳入自己的技能库。它们会确保你最大程度地让你的想法被你所说话的人重视和接受。
为了实现这一点，我们必须有一条参与规则，那就是不能使用笔记本电脑和手机。所以，请你们关掉这些设备，关好后我就开始。有人问为什么要有这个规则？
答案是我们人类只有一个语言处理器。如果你的语言处理器正在浏览网页或读邮件，那么……
你会分心，更糟的是，你还会让周围所有人分心。研究表明，而且更糟的是，如果我看到后面或前面某处有打开的笔记本电脑，我会抓狂，表现也会更差，这样一来，那些专心听讲的朋友们就得不到他们期待的效果了。那么开场白就到此为止，我们开始吧。首先要谈的当然是怎样
开始演讲。有些人认为正确的做法是以一个
故事开场。
玩笑我不建议这么做，原因是在演讲开始时，人们还在收拾笔记本电脑，他们正在适应你的说话参数，适应你的声音参数，他们还没准备好听笑话。
所以笑话效果不好，往往会冷场。你真正应该做的是以赋能承诺开始，你想告诉人们，在一小时结束时，他们会知道哪些在开始时不知道的事情。
这是一个赋能承诺，是大家在这里的原因。举个例子，比如在这60分钟结束时，你会学到一些你现在不知道的演讲技巧，而这些技巧中，有些会让你变得更出色。
这在你的生活中会带来不同，是的，这是一个赋能承诺，所以这是最好的开头方式。现在我已经简要谈到了如何开头，接下来我想做的是给你们一些我在演讲时总是牢记在心的技巧示例。
第一个技巧就是围绕主题反复循环，绕一圈再绕一圈。有些人说，告诉他们你想说的，再说一遍，然后说第三遍，好像人们不聪明似的，但重点是，
原因有很多，其中之一是无论讲座内容是什么，在任何时刻大约有20%的人会走神。所以如果你想确保每个人都能听懂的概率很高，你就需要说三遍。
所以循环是我演讲时总是考虑的事情之一。另一个我考虑的是，在解释我的想法时，我想在它周围筑起一道篱笆，
这样它就不会和其他人的想法混淆。如果你来自火星，而我教你什么是拱门，我可能会告诉你，那就是一个拱门，不要和其他一些人们可能认为是拱门的东西混淆，这不是拱门，那不是拱门。我在我的想法周围筑起篱笆，这样它就能和其他人的想法区分开来。
所以在更技术性的意义上，我可能会说，我的算法可能看起来和琼斯的算法相似，除了他的是指数级的，而我的是线性的，这就是在你的想法周围筑起篱笆，这样人们就不会混淆它和其他东西的关系。
这个清单上的第三个技巧是口头表达的概念。
关键在于停顿和标志性的节点。因为听众偶尔会走神，需要重新跟上思路，所以你得设置一些地标式的提示，告诉大家现在是个好时机回到演讲中来。比如说，我可以在演讲中这样说
让我先说一下演讲的大纲。首先，我们要谈的是如何开场；然后，我们会讨论这四个例子。在这四个例子中，我已经讲了第一个，关于循环；第二个，关于构建；现在第三个
就是语言上的间隔标记。所以我在列举，在用数字提示，让大家感觉到演讲中有个段落分界，你可以从那儿重新跟上思路。好了，现在我们继续，既然讲到这儿了，你们能猜到第四个观点是什么吗？
那就是能帮助听众重新进入状态的一个方法。
没错，提问。好的，谢谢大家，所以我们要提问。
于是我会问一个问题：沉默能持续多久？我能停顿多长时间？我数了七秒，对我来说，等待不说话，哪怕七秒也感觉像永恒。但这就是标准的时长。
你可以等待回答，当然，问题得精心挑选，不能太简单，否则大家不好意思说出答案；也不能太难，因为没人能答得上来。
所以，这里有一些范例技巧，你可以把它们装进你的“武器库”，逐步积累你的演讲点子。现在，如果这能让你相信演讲确实有门道、有知识，那么我已经成功了。
因为我想让你明白的是，如果你观察那些你钦佩、觉得有效的演讲者，并问自己他们为什么成功，那么你就能建立起自己的个人宝库，发展出你自己的风格。
这就是我的根本目标。接下来，在讨论其他内容之前，我们先谈谈时间和地点。
你觉得什么时候做讲座比较好？上午十一点？
对，原因是在麻省理工，大多数人那时候已经醒了，而且几乎没人再睡回笼觉。这不刚吃完饭，人们也不会因为各种事情而疲劳。这时候做讲座很棒。所以，这就引出下一个话题。
关于场地的问题，最重要的是场地要光线充足。
这个房间光线很好。其他类型的房间的问题在于，我们人类一旦灯光变暗或者房间昏暗，就会暗示我们应该去睡觉了。所以无论我去哪里演讲，
即使是今天，我见到视听技术人员的第一句话就是：'请保持灯光全亮。'他们可能会回答：'如果关灯，观众看幻灯片效果会更好。'然后我回答：'闭着眼睛看幻灯片是极其困难的。'
关于场地还有什么可说的？场地应该提前勘察，我指的是像抢劫银行那样的意思，就像如果你要抢银行，你会去银行那里提前踩点，
以确保行动当天没有意外。所以无论我去哪里演讲，我让主办方做的第一件事就是带我去我将要演讲的场地，以便我能处理任何奇怪的情况。
有时可能需要一些干预，有时只是需要我了解挑战是什么。所以今天早上我来这里时，我做了我常做的事：我想象所有座位都坐满了
不感兴趣的农场动物。这样我就知道，不管实际情况有多糟糕，也不会比那更糟。最后，场地应该有一定的人数。
如果这个大厅里只有10个人，每个人都会想这是怎么回事，这比空无一人有趣得多。所以你想选一个大小合适的场地，不一定要
爆满，但必须超过一半满。以上是关于时间和地点的一些想法。接下来我要谈的是关于白板、道具和幻灯片这些工具。
这些是行当里的工具。我相信，当你演讲的目的是提供信息时，白板是合适的工具；当你的目的是展示时，幻灯片是好的。但这是
我在提供信息、教学或讲课时使用的工具，有以下几个原因。首先，使用白板时，你有一种图形的
特性。情况是，当你有白板时，你可以轻松地利用在演示中使用图形的事实，这就是我喜欢的图形特性。其次，我喜欢的一个特性是速度属性，你在
黑板上书写的速度大约是人们吸收想法的速度。如果你快速翻过一堆幻灯片，没人能跟得上。最后，白板的一个很棒的属性是它可以作为一个
很多演讲新手突然意识到自己手的存在，好像双手是私密部位，不该在公共场合暴露。于是他们立刻把手插进口袋，这被视为一种冒犯。
在某些地方，或者可能把手放在背后，像这样。有一次我在塞尔维亚的一个修道院，我的主人，我们一进去，一位修女就走过来给我们端上点心。
我正要说不，谢谢，他却说：“吃吧，不然会饿死。”这是当地的风俗和礼貌。但随后，那位修女把我的手拉下来，像这样，因为在那个文化里，手放在背后是极其无礼的。
那么，这是为什么呢？通常认为这与是否隐藏武器有关。所以，如果你的手插在口袋里或放在背后，那么看起来你身上可能带着武器。
这就是我说的黑板的好处之一。现在你有事可做了，你可以指着黑板上的内容。我曾看西摩·帕尔特讲课，觉得非常棒。
所以我又去听了一次。第一次是吸收内容，第二次是观察风格。我发现帕尔特不停地指着黑板，我想了一会儿，注意到他指的东西和他说的话毫无关系。
但这确实是个有效的方法。所以，这只是关于黑板好处的一点。现在我想谈谈道具。关于道具的知识，剧作家最在行。
很多年前，我看过一部亨利克·易卜生的戏，叫《海达·加布勒》。我隐约记得是讲一个女人婚姻不幸，她丈夫和别人竞争一个学术职位，他会输。
部分原因是他很无聊，部分原因是竞争对手刚写了一本很棒的书。顺便说一句，那是在复印机和电脑出现之前。戏开演时，有一个大肚炉子。
戏开始时，炉门开着，里面只有一些微微发光的余烬。但那个炉子一直都在，随着剧情紧张升级，你会看到那份手稿，这个道具。
易卜生如此巧妙地运用它。你总觉得会发生什么，因为随着剧情发展，火越来越大，越来越热，最后完全吞噬一切，你就知道那份手稿会被扔进火里。
这是难忘的一幕，是我对这部剧的记忆。所以剧作家们深谙此道，但道具不是他们的专利。这里有一个使用道具的例子，同样来自西摩·帕尔特。
他讲到用正确的方式看待问题很重要，这个例子不仅教了这个道理，还能让你在机械工程朋友面前露一手。
方法如下：拿这个自行车轮，让它旋转起来，然后对轴施加扭矩，或者等价地，对着边缘吹气。问题是，它会转向那边还是这边？机械工程师们会立刻说：
“哦，我知道了，右手螺旋。”然后他们会把手指摆出某个姿势，但忘记如何准确地将手指与问题的各个部分对齐。所以通常他们答对的概率约为百分之五十。
他们受过的高等教育让他们答对的概率和抛硬币差不多。但不必如此，因为你可以换个角度思考问题。
方法如下：拿一些胶带，缠在轮子的一部分上，像这样。现在你思考的不是整个轮子，而是胶带下面的那一小部分。
那部分滚到顶部，这时你吹一口气，不要管轮子其他部分。胶带下的那一小块会怎么样？它肯定想朝那个方向去，因为你这样拍它，它已经在往下走了。
下一块也是一样。所以唯一可能发生的就是轮子朝那个方向倒下。这样你以后再也不会疑惑了，因为你在用正确的方式思考这个问题。
这个演示通过使用道具完成，你们可以在课后试试。
另一个我记忆犹新的例子是，我在上8.01课程时，艾伦·拉扎勒斯是当时讲师。他讲到能量守恒，动能和势能。天花板上垂下一根长线，
在26-100教室，挂着一个大得多的钢球，和这个差不多。拉扎勒斯把球靠在墙上，像这样。他把头紧紧贴在墙上稳住自己，然后松手。单摆花了很长时间荡来荡去，
然后轻轻碰到拉扎勒斯的鼻子。所以你有好几秒钟想：“这家伙真的相信能量守恒。”
不要在家里尝试。问题是，第一次做的时候，你可能不只是松手，有一种自然倾向会让你推一下。
所以，这就是关于这个主题的一些内容。
道具，你知道这很有意思。每当进行问卷调查，学生们总是说更多粉笔，更少幻灯片。嗯，为什么会这样呢？道具也总是很有效。为什么会这样呢？我会给你我这一派疯狂的观点，这与……有关
嗯，我称之为
共情镜像。当你坐在那里看着我写板书时，我相信你脑袋里那些小小的镜像神经元会被激活，你能感觉到自己在黑板上写字。甚至更甚，当我说到
这个钢球朝那边，又朝这边时，你能感受到那个球，仿佛你就是我。而你用幻灯片做不到，用图片也做不到。你需要看到它在物理世界里真实存在。这就是为什么我认为
对了，当然，这里面也涉及速度的问题，需要把它们分开。但我认为共情镜像是道具和黑板如此有效的原因。好吧，我们看看，哦，对了，还有一件事，关于
工具方面，那就是幻灯片的使用。我重复一遍，我认为它们用于展示想法，而非教授想法。但我们在求职演讲或会议演讲中就是展示想法，不是教授。所以让我稍微讲讲
我对此的看法。我记得有一次，在洛根机场的A航站楼，我刚从一个糟糕透顶的会议回来，航班也糟透了，就像一台不平衡的洗衣机。那是
我一生中唯一一次决定在去取车的路上停下来，喝杯咖啡，放松一下。我待了几分钟后，有人走过来对我说：“您是温斯顿教授吗？”我想是的，我
说“我不知道”，我想我是在试图搞笑。总之，他说：“我去欧洲做一个求职演讲，您介意点评一下我的幻灯片吗？”我说：“当然不介意。”他说：“你的幻灯片太多了，而且每张的字也太多。”他问：“您怎么知道的？”想
也许我以前看过他的演讲，但我没有。我回答：“因为这总是真的，总是有太多幻灯片，太多字。”所以让我展示一些如何不恰当地使用幻灯片的极端例子。为了这个演示，我
需要站到这边来。当我走到这边时，我可以开始说一些诸如：“你不应该做的事之一就是读出你的幻灯片。听众都会读，读只会
让他们厌烦。另外，你要确保每张幻灯片只有几个字，而且字要容易读。”我希望这让你抓狂，因为我正在犯各种错误。第一个是这张上的字太多。
第二张幻灯片上，我站在那边，然后它又滑到那边，你就像在打网球一样，视线在幻灯片和演讲者之间来回切换。你希望幻灯片只是你所说的内容的佐料，而不是主角，或者反过来。
那我们怎么解决这个问题呢？第一步，去掉那些总是分散注意力的背景杂物。第二步，去掉文字。当我把文字减少到这些的时候，
我以前读的所有内容，我现在都没有资格说了，因为幻灯片上没有。我不再读幻灯片了，但我说的是之前例子中写在幻灯片上的内容。那我们还能怎么简化呢？
我们可以去掉标志，我们不需要它们。简化，还能做什么？去掉标题。现在我想和你们谈谈准备幻灯片的一些规则。我告诉你们，标题不必，
放在上面。通过减少幻灯片上的文字数量，我让你更多地关注我，而不是关注幻灯片上写的内容。我之前提到过，我们只有一个语言处理器，我们可以用它来阅读，也可以用来听，
如果幻灯片上文字太多，就会迫使听众去读这些内容，而不去听。我的一个学生几年前做了一个实验，他教一些学生一些基于网络的编程，
一半的信息放在幻灯片上，他说了另一半，然后对于对照组，他反过来了。问题是，受试者，也就是他兄弟会里的大一新生，他们记得最清楚的是什么？是他说的，
还是他们在幻灯片上读到的？答案是，当幻灯片上有大量材料时，他们记住的是在幻灯片上读到的内容。他们根本不关注演讲者。事实上，在事后报告中，一个受试者说：
我希望你没说那么多，那太让人分心了。好吧，最后一点是消除杂乱。我听到一些杂乱的声音，不，不，甚至不需要那些项目符号。所以，文字过多的问题，是微软犯下的一个罪行，
它允许你使用太小的字体。所以你们都应该有一张像这样的样张，可以用来确定最小可读字号是多少。这很容易测量。Shiv，你觉得那些怎么样？哪个尺寸合适？那是什么？
那个尺寸合适，是的，最小大概40或50。他说40或50，我觉得差不多。35就太小了，不一定是你看不清，而是因为你可能用它来放太多文字。我们还有什么其他罪行？
我们有激光笔罪行。不，不是那个。你知道，在过去没有激光笔的时候，我们用木棍，人们会挥舞着这些东西，很快就像，
一场混乱的旋转比赛。所以，这就是我过去推荐的对付这种情况的办法。
这个例子说明了道具的运用。吉姆·格拉斯，大约20年前我听过那场演讲，然后我记得那场演讲，就是你弄断指针的那场。令人惊叹的是，道具往往就是人们记住的东西。
现在我们不再有实体指针了，我们用的是激光笔。真是奇怪，怎么没有更多人因此引发癫痫呢？但接下来通常会发生的是，看这画面，多么美妙的递归图啊，而我可以成为它的一部分，把激光束正好对准我脑后上方那里。你看到了什么？你看到的是我的后脑勺，没有眼神交流，没有互动，什么都没有。
我坐在那里，和……
有个学生有天看演讲时说，你知道吗，我们都可以离开，他也不会发现。所以，当你用激光笔的时候，你就得转头去指东西，而这样一来，
你就失去了和观众的眼神交流。你不想那样做。那么，如果你需要在图像中指出某个东西，又不想用激光笔指，该怎么办呢？这就是方法：放一个小箭头，
然后说，看那个箭头一号末尾的家伙。你不需要激光笔就能做到。
当人们请我评审演讲时，我会让他们把讲稿打印出来，摊在桌上。这样一来，就很容易看出演讲是否过于沉重，文字太多，没有呼吸感，没有留白，没有足够的图像。
这是一个典型的过于沉重的演讲例子。这位演讲者利用小字体，尽可能地在幻灯片上塞入更多内容，这里有很多问题，但我主要想说明的是它太沉重了。
相比之下，这是另一个演讲，我几年前做的。它不是深度技术性的演讲，但我展示给你看，是因为它有空隙。它大部分是图片。
有三四张幻灯片上有文字，但当我讲到这些时，我会给观众时间去阅读。它们之所以存在，是因为可能有历史意义。第一张带大量文字的幻灯片，是1957年达特茅斯AI会议提案的摘录。
那是一次非同寻常的会议，提案中的历史摘录有助于让观点深入人心。还有什么呢？哦，对了。
你今天的词汇是“NAX Lon”。它的意思是，这种幻灯片在你的演讲中只能出现一次。这张幻灯片几年前有些影响力，因为它展示了治理的复杂性。
通过展示阿富汗的复杂程度，让听众觉得难以理解，这正是重点所在，但这样的例子不能多用，一场演讲、一篇论文或一本书里只能有一个。
这就是“epex Lan”的意思，我给你们展示了一些“罪行”，你们可能会问这些情况真的存在吗？确实存在。
比如手插口袋的毛病，还有时间和地点选择的问题。比如去BTO剧场该怎么走：先从媒体实验室的台阶下去，穿过一片开阔地。
然后右转进入走廊，每次走到那里，我都在想拐角处会不会有刑具。再往里走，就到了那个阴暗的地方，所以叫它“巴罗斯剧场”很贴切。
叫它“巴罗斯剧场”是因为可以看电影，但不适合做演讲。不过也有例外，比如我之前在斯塔达听过一次演讲，注意演讲者离幻灯片很远。
演讲者用激光笔，你可能会问这是怎么回事。顺便说一下，这是演示的第80张幻灯片，而且是以文字开头的，这是10张总结幻灯片中的第一张。那么听众什么反应？
这是会议赞助商，他在看邮件；这是联合赞助商，他在研究午餐菜单。这个人看起来在听，但这是静止照片，如果是视频，你会看到……
就像这样。所以确实会发生。好了，工具就快速回顾到这里。
现在我想谈谈一些特殊情况。我们可以聊聊如何传递信息，也就是我现在在做的，但我只说几点。
在这种演讲中，你需要像我现在这样，在开头给出一个承诺，就像我们这个小时的开头一样。但接下来问题是：如何激励人？我讲这个主题很久了。
几年前，系主任让我给新教师讲这个，并强调如何激励学生。奇怪的是，我之前没想过这个问题。
所以我开始调查。我和一些大一新生顾问、资深教授以及其他人都聊过，问他们是如何被激励的。我发现大一新生通常是被某个高中老师激励的，他们告诉学生“你行”的。
而资深教授是被帮助他们用新视角看问题的人激励的。而所有人的共同点是……
当有人展现出对所做事情的热情时，会让人受到启发。对我来说这很容易，因为你知道，我研究人工智能，怎么会有人对人工智能不感兴趣呢？
人工智能对吧？如果你对人工智能都不感兴趣，那你可能对有趣的事情都没兴趣。所以我在教AI课的时候，很自然地会讲我觉得酷的东西，还有某个新想法有多令人兴奋。
所以这就是那种能产生影响的热情表达，同时也能传授知识。关于启发这个问题，哦对了，在承诺阶段你当然也可以表达出来。
好的内容有多酷呢？让我举个例子，一堂课可以这样开场：我要讲的是资源分配，这跟你在考虑某些事情时想到的那些东西是一样的，也是你需要的那些想法。
把飞机分配到航班时刻表上，或者安排工厂的生产计划之类的，但例子是美国各州涂色，相邻的州颜色不能一样。接下来就是这样，这是我在课程开始时展示的
一种给这些州涂色的方法。你可能会说，为什么不等到它结束呢？你想那样做吗？不，我们可不会等到它结束，因为太阳都爆炸把地球吞没了，它还没涂完呢。
这个项目虽然结束了，但稍微调整了一下运作方式，我告诉我的学生们，在接下来的50分钟里你们就会明白。这就是你得到的，是不是很酷？你知道的，你得对事物感到惊奇。
把一个原本需要比太阳系寿命还长的计算时间缩短到几秒钟，这就是我说的提前给出承诺，并对你讲的内容表现出热情。那么，这一小部分的最后一项
是关于人们在麻省理工学院认为他们做的事情。你问一位教授最重要的目的是什么，他们会说：“嗯，我最重要的事情是教人们如何思考。”然后你说：“哦，那很好，”
“你是怎么教人们思考的呢？”他们会茫然地愣住。没有人能很好地回答这个自然的后续问题。那么，怎么教人思考呢？我相信我们是会讲故事的动物，我们
从童年听童话故事开始培养我们理解和运用故事的能力，并继续在法学院、商学院、医学院、工程学院等专业学院以及整个一生中持续这种训练。所以
如果思考就是这样一回事，那么当你想教人思考时，你给他们提供需要了解的故事，关于这些故事他们需要提出的问题，以及分析这些故事的机制。
组合故事的方法，以及评估故事可靠性的方法。我认为这就是教人如何思考时应该做的。但这些都是关于教育的，而你们中的许多人在这里，不一定是为了这个。
而是为了说服这部分，这可以分成几个类别：口试、求职演讲、成名。对于口试，我不多说，只是它们过去比现在吓人得多。在过去，
阅读外语文献是其中一部分，而且挂科率很高。当你回顾这些失败时，最常见的失败原因
是没有定位和没有练习。所谓定位，是指把你的研究放在背景中很重要。这是一个全世界都在追逐的问题，在我之前的30年里没有任何进展。
每个人都在寻找解决方案，因为它会对很多其他事情产生影响。所以，这就是在时间、地点和领域上的定位。至于练习，是的，练习很重要，但这并不意味着把你的幻灯片
给和你同办公室的人看。问题在于，如果人们知道你在做什么，他们会幻觉你的演讲中有不存在的材料。这其实是个变种场景。
实际上，找导师帮忙调试演讲并不是很好，因为他们已经知道你在做什么，还会产生幻觉，觉得你的演讲里有些根本没讲的内容。所以你得找几个朋友，他们不知道你在做什么。
然后，在练习的时候，你可以先说，“如果你们不能把我弄哭，我就不把你们当朋友了。”这样，到了正式的口试时，就会觉得轻松了。
嗯，困难在于，你受到的批评数量跟年龄成正比。年纪越大，越清楚自己的位置，但年轻人嘛，总想向长辈展示自己有多聪明。
他们非常非常恶毒，所以每当你有机会遇到一位头发花白的考官委员会时，那就是你想要的。关于我没列出的这一点，我就简单说两句。
让我们进入求职演讲的主题。多年前，我在圣地亚哥的一家酒吧里，我是海军科学委员会的成员，我和几位同事坐在一起，包括来自...的多洛雷斯·埃德。
科罗拉多大学的那位女士让我嫉妒得想吐口水，因为她写了21本书，而我只写了177本。另一位是德州大学的比尔·韦伦，他是电磁学专家，他知道怎么用轨道炮来...
他们是想穿过坦克装甲的钢条，这些人很有趣，所以我说，呃，你们在寻找教职候选人时会看重什么？多洛雷斯立刻说，他们必须向我们展示他们有某种远见，比尔紧接着说
他们必须向我们展示他们做了什么
哦，听起来不错。我说，然后我问他们，候选人需要多长时间来确立这两点？你觉得呢，和他们的答案比比看。
五分钟。所以，如果你在五分钟内没有表达你的愿景，没有告诉人们你做了什么，那你就已经输了。所以你必须做到这一点，让我提一下相关的几点。
首先，愿景部分是关于人们关心的问题，以及你方法中的新意。
所以，问题是理解人类智能的本质，方法则是问是什么让我们与黑猩猩和尼安德特人不同。是仅仅数量上的差异，还是我们在某种连续的方式上更聪明一点？
还是我们拥有根本不同的东西，而黑猩猩和尼安德特人没有？答案是，是的，我们确实有不同之处。我们是符号生物，因为我们是符号生物，我们可以……
嗯，我们可以构建关于关系和事件的符号描述，我们可以把它们串联起来讲故事，而因为能讲故事，这就是我们的不同之处。这就是我的标准演讲，这就是我大多数关于我个人研究的演讲的开场方式。
如何表达你做了什么？通过列出解决该问题所需的步骤。你不必已经完成所有步骤，但你可以说，这就是需要做的事情。
举个例子，这就是需要做的：我们需要指定某种行为，我们需要列举出处理该行为的约束条件，我们必须实现一个系统，
因为我们是工程师，我们不认为我们理解了一个东西，除非我们能构建它。我们构建了这样一个系统，今天我们将向你展示它。那将是列举一系列步骤来实现愿景的例子。
然后如此这般，最后你通过列举你的贡献来总结。
这有点像这些步骤的镜像，有助于确立你做了什么。所以，这是一个做技术演讲的通用框架。今天只剩下几件事要做，成名是我们的下一个议程。
因为一旦你得到了工作，你需要考虑一下如何让你的工作得到认可。
首先，为什么你应该关心成名？我想过这个，与一次我参加的筹款活动有关，那是一个为拯救威尼斯免于下沉、避免艺术品被毁而筹款的活动，总之，
我当时坐在这里，JC坐在那里，那是已故的朱莉娅·查尔德。
随着夜晚的进行，越来越多的人来找朱莉娅签名或表达她改变了他们的生活，这样反复发生。最后我转向朱莉娅，
我说，查尔德女士，出名有趣吗？她想了一下，说，你会习惯的。但你猜我想到什么？你永远不会习惯被忽视。所以，这是个思考方式，你的想法就像你的孩子，
你不想让他们衣衫褴褛地走进世界。所以你要做的是确保你有这些技巧、这些机制、这些关于如何呈现你的想法的思考，这样它们就能被认可其内在价值。
这就是为什么关注包装是合理的事情。那么，如何让别人记住你呢？我喜欢称之为温斯顿之星，我即将阐述的每一项都以S开头。所以，如果你希望你的演讲想法被记住，你需要做的其中一件事是确保你的工作有某种象征符号。
这个“拱门”的例子实际上来自我很多年前的博士论文。
在那个时候，我的工作中，这个关于拱门学习的工作变得有点出名，我不知道为什么。直到很多年后，我才意识到，那个工作意外地包含了这颗星的所有元素。所以，
第一个元素是有一种象征，就是拱门本身。
接下来你需要的是某种口号，一种能成为工作抓手的短语。在这种情况下，这个短语是“一次学习”。之所以说一次，是因为我写的程序从每个呈现的例子中学到了明确的东西，
所以，在从一个基于这种配置的模型转变为不是基于这种配置的拱门时，程序学会了它必须在顶部。一次学习，这就是一个简单的口号。现在我们需要一个惊喜，
是的，惊喜是你不需要一百万个例子来学习某样东西，你只需要一个例子，如果你足够聪明地适当利用那个例子的话。这就是惊喜：从每一个例子中你都能学到明确的东西。
接下来一个要点是“突出想法”
我说的突出想法，不是指重要，而是指一个能让人记住的点。有趣的是，有些论文有太多好点子，反而让人搞不清重点，因为到底哪个才是核心呢？所以你需要一个突出的想法。
这里突出的想法就是“几乎成功”的概念
你看，这个不是拱门，但差一点点就是了，所以它算是“几乎成功”。最后，你需要讲述你如何做到、它如何运作、为什么重要的故事。这就是关于如何让你的工作获得认可，而不仅仅是出名。
好了，我们快结束了，因为我们已经到了最后一项：如何收尾。说到收尾，问题来了：最后一张幻灯片应该是什么？
最后的结语应该是什么？
所以，在最后一张幻灯片上，让我给你一些可能的例子。比如说这一张，你可能会看到这张幻灯片，然后心里想：麻省理工有一千名教师，干得不错，但也不是什么大不了的事，那只是很小的一部分工作。
如果你除以一千，那么当你在演讲结束时展示一长串合作者名单时，这其实是一种让人失望的表现，因为这暗示着没人知道你到底做了什么重要的事。你必须
感谢你的合作者，对吧？那么，你该在哪里做这件事呢？不是放在最后一张幻灯片上，而是放在第一张。所有这些都在第一张幻灯片上，这些就是合作者。所以，你不要把他们放在最后，不要用这样的幻灯片。那这样如何呢？
这是最糟糕的结束演讲的方式，因为这张幻灯片可能会在屏幕上停留二十分钟，我亲眼见过。它浪费了宝贵的空间，也浪费了告诉听众你是谁的机会。那这张呢？
我经常看到这种情况，但从来没有人记下来。而且它也浪费了机会，天哪，更糟的是，所有这些幻灯片对你毫无帮助，它们浪费了你告诉听众你是谁、你留下什么印象的机会。
那这张呢？这个看起来不错，或许乍一看是这样，但问题是，如果你说“这些是我的结论”，这些结论完全合理，但没人关心这些，他们关心的是你……”
已经做了的，这就是为什么你最后一页幻灯片应该标注“贡献”，这与我之前讲过的关于求职演讲应该像三明治的说法相呼应。最后一页，就是人们提问和离开时留在屏幕上的那一页，应该放上你的贡献。
这里有一个我自己常讲的内容的例子。是的，这就是我经常谈论的。这些是我通常要展示的内容，
然后我等人们读完，最后一条是“这是我们从中得到的”，这就是贡献行的例子。好了，那另一部分呢？你知道你的最后一页幻灯片已经放上去了，
那是一张贡献页。但你总得告诉人们你讲完了，所以让我们看看几种可能的方式。一个办法是在最后几句话里讲个笑话。
没关系，到那时候人们已经适应了你的声音和节奏，他们准备好听笑话了。有一次我和同事道格·莱纳特坐在另一家酒吧里，这次是在德克萨斯州的奥斯汀，道格是个
非常出色的演讲者，于是我对道格说：“道格，你是出色的演讲者，你的秘诀是什么？”他说：“哦，我总是以笑话结尾，这样人们会觉得整个过程都很有趣。”所以笑话确实有效。那这个呢——
“谢谢大家。”我不推荐这个，这是个软弱的方式。如果你以“谢谢”结束演讲，你不会下地狱，但这是个软弱的方式。原因是：当你说“谢谢”，甚至更糟的“感谢聆听”时，你暗示着
每个人都是出于礼貌才待这么久，他们其实非常想离开，但太客气了所以坚持下来，而你就是在感谢这个。所以一旦热烈的掌声开始了，你可以用口型说声谢谢，这没问题，
但最后做的事情不应该是说“谢谢”。你会说：“可是大家不都说谢谢吗？”但大家都做的事不一定是对的。我想举例说明
一些演讲如何不说“谢谢”也能结束。我喜欢从政治演讲中找例子，但最近听到的不太好，所以我得往回找找。这是克里斯蒂州长，他有一年做了共和党大会的主题演讲，
这是他演讲的结尾，我们看看他是怎么做的：“团结一致，我们将再次为美国的伟大而站起，为了我们的子孙后代。上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。”这是经典的
祝福式结尾：“上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。”我不想偏袒某一方，所以最好也换成民主党大会的主题演讲，那一年是比尔·克林顿发表的，他可是深知如何
演讲的。“如果那是你想要的，如果那是你相信的，你必须投票，你必须再次选举巴拉克·奥巴马总统。上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。”
现在，美国，看好了。咱们稍微倒回去，重新放一遍。我想让你们看到，有那么一刻，他几乎是把嘴唇抿紧了，强忍着不说“谢谢”。然后呢，在另一个地方，他又来了个小敬礼。所以这次看的时候，留意这两处。
如果那是你们想要的，如果那是你们所坚信的，你们必须去投票，必须再次选巴拉克·奥巴马当总统。上帝保佑你们，上帝保佑美国。看，大家这会儿都抿着嘴呢，就这儿有掌声。
好的，我觉得那很不错。现在我们从这个演讲中学到了什么呢？嗯，我想我可以这样结束这次演讲：愿上帝保佑你们，愿上帝保佑麻省理工学院。但可能这样不太妥当，所以，我们还是来说说你们应该记住的要点吧。
你要是实在走不掉，也不用非得说谢谢，还有其他办法。有意思的是，久而久之人们也摸索出了些套路。比如在天主教的古老拉丁弥撒里，结尾会说‘Ite Missa Est’，大致意思就是‘好了，弥撒结束了，你们可以回家了’。
当然，在音乐会上，你知道什么时候该鼓掌吗？不是等曲子结束，而是等指挥转过身来的时候。
然后与乐队首席握手，这些惯例告诉你活动已经结束了。所以这些都是可能的结束方式，但还有一种可能，那就是你可以向观众致敬。
我的意思是，你可以表达你多么珍惜在这里的时光。比如，我会说，在这里真的很开心，看到你们在麻省理工学院做的事情也非常令人着迷。
在这里，我受到了很多启发和挑战，大家提出的问题让我很兴奋，这真的非常棒。我期待未来多次回来。这就是向观众致敬的一种方式。
好了，就是这样。我很高兴你们能来，因为你们在这里，说明你们明白如何展示和包装自己的想法是一件重要的事情。我向你们致敬。
而且，我建议你们以后再来，并带上朋友。 [掌声]